[Music]
when i was a little kid
i had a lot of nightmares which was
weird
because i had a very happy and healthy
and safe childhood
i had a loving family so it's just weird
being a kid is weird brains are weird
life is weird
whatever i had a lot of nightmares
and some of the bad ones rank among my
most vivid childhood memories
i had dreams about evil trees and dreams
about giant eels
it was about shape-shifting grandmas
yeah those stay with you over time
not being able to fall asleep because
you're afraid when you're a kid is
a very dark thing but the strange thing
is i really wouldn't change any of that
i actually kind of treasure it
that's because having nightmares as a
kid and spending time with that gave me
two
massive blessings and i'll share one now
and one at the end
the first is that i became very very
good at figuring out whether i was in a
dream or real life
and knowing the difference is everything
nightmares really tend to
lose their edge when you know they're
not real things chase you a little bit
slower
and scary things become smaller and the
world just gets a little more pliable
and weird things start to happen you can
do strange things
when you know it's not real this kind of
overwhelming euphoria
and a feeling of empowerment when i
figured out that i could fly in my
dreams
as a kid it was profoundly cathartic
it was healing because it allowed me to
take something which terrified me about
my brain and being alive and turned into
something
creative and joyful and actually
welcomed my nightmares because they
helped me figure out
that i was in a dream
and it wasn't until i turned 18 that i
realized this wasn't my private
mental invention to beat nightmares but
a phenomenon called lucid dreaming
and lucid dreaming is where you figure
out that you're in a dream and you start
to control it
you can do whatever you want you can you
can fly you can breathe underwater
you can move things with your mind you
can shoot ice out of your hands
there's really no known limits to what
you can do in a lucid dream
and when i got to university i stumbled
on the work of stephen laburge who's a
psychophysiology phd
from stanford who in the 80s developed
the foundational
literature on what lucid dreaming is and
how to do it
and i just fell all the way down this
rabbit hole i just devoured his work
and there was this online corpus of
lucid dreaming techniques put together
by a very
eccentric community of lucid dreamers on
how to do it and i wasn't the only one
studying this there were other students
on campus
who had mastered the art of lucid
dreaming flying was nothing to them they
were having out-of-body experiences
and composing music in their dreams and
raising landscapes with a swipe of their
hand
and the craziest thing that i learned
falling down that rabbit hole
is that the techniques on how to lucid
dream can be learned
practiced and mastered by anyone willing
to try
so i'm just going to walk you through
some of those techniques that i've found
incredibly useful
over the past few years
so there's three fundamental gates to
lucid dreaming and every night that you
don't have a lucid dream
you have failed to pass through one of
these three gates
they are in order realize did you
realize that you were in a dream
that's step one remain
once you realize that you're in a dream
were you able to stay there without
waking up
and then most importantly did you
remember that that dream happened at all
so i'll just start by talking about the
first one which is also my favorite
how do you have that epiphany where you
realize that you're in a dream
it's this electric moment and the only
way to
create that moment is to ask as often as
possible in reality
am i dreaming right now and expert lucid
dreamers are checking many times a day
whether they're in a dream or reality
so i'm just going to walk you through
some of those reality checks that you
can use to distinguish
number one and i hope people will do
this with me this is your north star for
freaking out if you're a dream
shut your nose with your hand and then
try and breathe through it
this should not be working
but if it is working congratulations
you're almost definitely dreaming right
now
this talk is about to get way more
interesting for you
but for the rest of us it's just
important to remember that
breathing is always regulated by what
you're doing in reality if your
sleeping body is breathing you're always
going to be able to breathe in a dream
this is a great way to distinguish
another easy one
is that you can take out your phone and
look at the home screen and look at the
time
and put it away and then look back at it
again if the numbers change
significantly
or if they don't look like numbers at
all you're very likely to be in a dream
that's just because brains have a hard
time holding alphanumeric symbols in
place
while you're in a dream they shift
around a lot
then there's this other one which is uh
kind of frightening honestly
look at your hands and just count the
fingers
if you have about 10 and they look like
hands
you're probably in reality but if not
you're almost definitely in a dream
this is very consistent i just have to
warn you once you realize you've never
had normal hands
in your dreams your entire life and
didn't notice it can kind of blow you
away
this one's also a bit more discreet than
like the nose thing so that's a personal
preference i'll let you decide
and then finally i had to include this
one because it's just too weird light
switches don't work in dreams
they just don't brains can't handle
changing the visual landscape of a space
that quickly
um and let's just admit that plenty of
light switches don't work in real life
so
you can get some false positives with
this
so just be careful with that okay
so once you've achieved uh lucidity and
you're having that moment
how do you avoid waking up immediately
this is actually a lot harder than it
sounds
people under appreciate this because
most lucid dreams will last only like
five or ten seconds which
is a bummer okay so this is a bit more
art than science but really important
you have to act super nonchalant as soon
as you realize you're in a dream
you just have to act like you don't care
at all and you're gonna get a rush of
adrenaline
and your heartbeat will go up so you
actually have to pretend like someone's
watching you
i have to do this every time um and the
point is that if you can get through
this 5 or 10 second window
of over excitement then you're probably
going to have the whole dream which is
great
and then more concretely you have to
focus on your body in the dream
not your body in real life so the way i
do that is in the dream i just rotate my
hands in little circles
and i just look at my body and um
the point is that you can't become aware
of your sleeping body in your bed if you
do that you're going to get ejected
out of your dream and thrown back into
that body um so that'll end it
immediately
okay so you've had a lucid dream how do
you actually remember that it happened
and this is so important and so
difficult because if you don't remember
it it's really as if it didn't happen at
all
and this is hard 95 to 99 of dreams are
totally forgotten
and many people report not having dreams
at all
which to me is as tragic as it is
totally misinformed because
they've shown in labs over and over that
everyone dreams every night it's just a
matter of remembering it
so many people know that dream journals
really help with this you can train that
muscle
using a dream journal but they just
don't seem to work for a lot of people
and the reason is that they're missing a
key aspect which is that the dream
journal has to be at
arm's length from where you're sleeping
it has to be under your pillow under
your mattress or on your bedside table
and the reason for that is that standing
up and moving around is what wipes your
dream memory completely
you have to practice remembering
everything from a lying down position
and if you don't have a dream journal
handy you can just use a smartphone and
take a voice memo too
any bullets or fragments you remember
help with this and it is a muscle that
you can train
over time and then much more bizarrely
and this has been shown to work by the
national sleep foundation
in empirical studies just say out loud i
want to remember my dreams before you go
to bed
this actually works and the basis for
this is in
uh the psychology dark magic of
cognitive dissonance and we definitely
don't have time to talk about that but
suffice to say this is easy and we
should all be doing it
okay so those are some of the important
techniques but why does this matter why
am i even talking about this
flying is cool we like flying
it's a proven nightmare therapy we like
that nightmares are bad
um but i think it's worth admitting that
no one really knows
why this is valuable or even why it's
possible like there's no scientific
consensus on why humans need to
sleep much less why they dream and lucid
dreaming is thought to be more a bug
than a feature of human development
so why is this worth our time and
attention
the second blessing that having
nightmares as a kid gave me was a truth
that i've always taken to be
self-evident which is that having a
healthy relationship with your mind
is everything that's everything that's
what life is life is whatever happens in
your brain before you die
and on one hand that's terrifying
because brains aren't always good
they'll sometimes do stuff like
give kids nightmares which is weird
and living life in the cage of your mind
is kind of a bummer
but over time in the process of
spiritual the the
process of lucid dreaming which i can
only describe as spiritual
um i've come to realize that turning
your mind into a creative space
where you can experiment and witness
yourself
and have that moment of awakening where
you're like oh these colors
and these faces and these landscapes
that's all me
and just witness the mystery of your
mind
that's among the greatest joys there is
in life
and people wake up from lucid dreams
excited to
listen to what their mind is telling
them and then witness that mystery
throughout their life
and understand their mind better so i
encourage all of you
just try it just play with it
it may change for you as it did for me
how you experience life in your own mind
thank you
you